- All right, let's start.
Thank you so much for joining
us for this exciting event.
My name is Florian Carle.
I'm the manager of the
Yale Quantum Institute
and I'm delighted to see
so many of you attendees
non-technical talk presented to you.
So we usually would have you over
on the Yale campus for this talk,
but for the time being
all we can offer for you
is the seminar remotely,
but we are delighted to
have A. Douglas Stone
to give us this talk on quantum science
and what led humanity
to be on the verge of harvesting
quantum computer power.
So A. Douglas Stone is
the YQI deputy director
and also the Carl A. Morse Professor
of Applied Physics and
professor of physics.
He's the author of
"Einstein and the Quantum:
"The Quest of the Valiant Swabian",
and you'll see that some of
the content from the book
will be on the presentation tonight.
Professor Stone presented
the stork in Aspen
in front of industry and
government agency leaders
in the last winter at the quantum summits,
and we are very pleased to have the talk
broadcast for all of you
tonight and for the public.
For all 145 of you right
now welcome to the seminar.
The mandate of the Yale Quantum Institute
is really to bring a quantum science
and all our research and
work to you and to the public
and explain to you what we're doing
and how this research done by
so many students, postdocs,
and researcher in our labs
will benefit the general
public in the round.
Before we start this talk,
I would like to give you
a few technical comments.
You will be able to split the screen
between the slides and the video
and you can adjust the size of the speaker
so you can see our Douglas
Stone talk in a second,
and you can also type all your
questions in the Q&A feature
at the bottom of the screen.
We will take your question
either during the talk,
if the pertinence right now,
or we'll do a Q&A session afterwards.
So feel free to type your
question in the back.
The talk will be recorded and hosted
on the Yale Quantum
Institute website for replay,
and without further further ado,
I would like to really
welcome Douglas Stone
and have a delightful evening.
- Hello, guests in cyberspace.
I'm so pleased you could
come and hear this talk
which as Florian said is
supposed to be non technical.
So for the technical people
who've been nice enough
to tune in and see me
I'll do the best I can,
just forgive me for oversimplifying things
and I'm very pleased that
I can do this as a webinar,
where I get to speak in a room.
Unfortunately it's a room
with one very socially
distant person here, Florian,
and it's much nicer than
hunching over my screen
for the Zoom conference,
but I don't get to see your smiling faces.
I don't get to hear your laughter,
which I hope will be copious,
and I also don't get to see
you're bored or confused looks.
So I'm just going to think positively
about what's going on
out there and go forward.
So I wrote a whole book about
Einstein in quantum mechanics
and in the preface of that book I said,
"I chose deliberately to
be quite brief on questions
"such as fundamental indeterminism
"in nature and entanglement",
which are very much actually
the topic of today's talk,
and the question is why?
And the answer is pretty simple.
Quantum mechanics is not rocket science.
This stuff is really hard.
It's really hard.
It's really, really, really hard.
So it's not something
that I wanted to impose
on the unsuspecting public
unless it was really necessary.
So I try to avoid many of
the most challenging topics,
which now unfortunately or fortunately
are central to this talk.
So this is base what the
less of you may feel,
but hopefully we'll avoid this.
So why now?
Well, the reason now
that I'm venturing into
this difficult territory
is that I show here a map
where the red dots illustrate
new funding for quantum science
adding up to about $15 billion,
and I should say that there's
been lots of quantum science
since 1925 going on,
but this is a new type of quantum science
which we call quantum information science,
and $15 billion of new
funding put in perspective
the full budget of NSF
in a year is 7 billion.
So it's quite a bit
and you see that the big
red dot there is China,
and China has made it clear
that they're hoping to dominate
the modern communications
and information processing
technology sector,
and so certainly they are
putting a lot of effort into this
as is the United States and other places.
Here's a list of corporate involvement
in the United States of
America with quantum science.
You see these four web tech giants,
Amazon, Google, Microsoft, IBM,
as well as other well-known
names and a number of startups.
I wanna make a shout out
to Quantum Circuits Inc.
which is the local startup in New Haven,
which was founded by Robert
Schoelkopf and others,
and also abroad there this
bunch of famous tech names
that you can see here including Alibaba,
which is almost a trillion
dollar web company in China,
and last about a year and
a half ago, Jack Hidary,
who was head of AI and
Quantum Information Science
at Google X came in or gave a talk,
and when asked said that
quantum information science
will be at least as important
as AI in the tech industry,
artificial intelligence that is,
and here's a list of new quantum centers
all founded in the last five to 10 years.
Many of our peers appear on this list,
including the Yale Quantum
Institute, of course,
and there are major international centers
which I haven't listed all of,
and most recently DOE has
set up a few quantum hubs
around the nation
and Yale is the co-lead of one
in this part of the country
with all these other partner
institutions listed below
for really focusing on the
kinds of technology we do
here at Yale,
and this has, yeah, it's
$120 million in funding
over five years and possibly renewable.
Now, I wanna start by saying
there was no field of
quantum information science
when I got my PhD,
and to illustrate how long ago that was,
this is a picture of me
on the MIT Physics Department soccer team,
that skinny guy with lots of hair.
So you can see that that was a while ago.
The things that were being studied then
were the Higgs boson,
gravitational waves, dark matter,
and string theory.
So all these cutting edge
things you've heard about,
even more recently, in physics,
were actually already targets
for big chunks of the physics community
and astrophysics, et cetera then,
but not quantum information science.
Quantum information science didn't exist,
but the precursors were people who worried
about the philosophical
foundations of quantum mechanics,
that worried about the measurement problem
in quantum mechanics
and a little bit about irreversibility
in the direction of time,
very much fringe activities
that weren't considered real physics.
Okay, well, now, of course,
this is accepted as maybe the
most exciting frontier area
in physical science
and with the connection to
computer science and mathematics,
and it just came out of a left field
in a way that I'm going to describe.
So you can call that
scientific revolution or transformative,
but I think it's the most surprising
and exciting development in
physics in the last 50 years,
in my humble opinion.
So I felt we should try
to engage the public
about this quantum information science
because it is so novel
and it could be quite important as well.
So the outline of my talk
is I'm gonna begin with
a historical context.
Of course, this is sort of my thing.
Quantum mechanics was invented
as the theory of the microscopic world,
atoms, molecules nuclei, the
origin of light and heat,
and it was developed
between about 1900 and 1930,
and there were conceptual challenges
with the new quantum theory
related to the idea of
superposition and entanglement
of the effect of measurement
and a changing paradigm
for what existed in nature,
but in the maturing period
between 1930 and 1980
there was great success,
but constraints on what
we could actually predict
from quantum theory that
I'm gonna talk about,
and it was only in 1980s
that this radical fringe movement formed
that began to study quantum
information science,
and then in the 1990s
there was a Eureka moment,
which created this worldwide
race to perfect the technology
and specifically to
build a quantum computer,
which I'm gonna talk about,
and then since 2000,
there's been an effort to
actually make this a reality.
The early work was all theoretical work,
mainly theoretical work,
and actually the quantum
computer is a new kind of machine
unlike any of the others we built,
even using quantum
mechanics to build them,
and I'm gonna explain why it's
such a new kind of machine,
and then finally,
I'll briefly talk about the
social and economic impact
of quantum information
science and technology.
So, in 1900, the exploration
of inner space began.
Through the 19th Century
physicists and chemists had hypothesized
that they were smallest constituents
of matter, atoms and molecules
and were able to explain
the property of gases
and some of the properties of heat
and the flow of heat
using this point of view,
and during that period
the working assumption
was that the same laws of
physics, of Newtonian physics
and the electromagnetism
of Maxwell and Faraday
would apply also to these atoms
possibly with new forces
that we would discover
and that turned out not
at all to be the case.
So, and this word quantum arose
and that's the first question one asks.
Why is it called quantum mechanics?
And it was introduced
by Max Planck in 1900
and he was trying to explain
the vibrations of molecules,
which both act as a
microscopic source of heat
and also as a source of thermal radiation,
and he was trying to
explain the observations
of this thermal radiation
and he was able to explain that
only by assuming that the
vibrational energy was quantized
and the smallest unit epsilon,
we physicist are contractually required
to use Greek letters here
to make it sound more fancy.
So epsilon is the smallest unit of energy.
Nu is the frequency of the vibration,
and h has this new constant
that Planck discovered
called Planck constant,
and because of this quantization
this vibrating molecule was assumed
to only be able to take certain energies
equal to an integer number times h nu,
and this is may not
immediately strike you
as being totally crazy,
but it is totally crazy
in a certain sense.
So the macroscopic analog
of this simple oscillator
would be a pendulum, right?
And when the pendulum is just facing down,
let's say it has its minimum energy,
just potential energy, no kinetic energy,
and then when I displace
it and let it move
it gets kinetic energy along
with the potential energy,
and the more I displace it
the more kinetic energy it's going to get.
So it looks like the energy
that I can give to this oscillator
is related to the continuity of space
and must be continuous
'cause it seems like I
could display by any amount,
but the implication of Planck's hypothesis
was that that's not the case
that actually only certain magnitudes
or amplitudes of vibration were allowed,
something totally outside
of Newtonian physics.
Now, the young Einstein showed up
and he contributed to this.
Planck had not embraced his hypothesis
as a new law of physics
that would change mechanics,
but Einstein very much did
and in 1907 he wrote the following words,
for although one has thought before
that the motion of molecules
obeys the same laws
that hold for the motion of bodies
in our world of sense perception,
we must now assume that the
energy of elementary structures
can only assume the values
zero, h nu, two h nu, et cetera.
Okay, now, related to
this he had introduced...
So this was, as I said,
a radical violation of Newtonian mechanics
and it hints at a coming revolution
which Einstein was embracing,
and in fact, in 1905,
earlier he had proposed
thinking about Planck's work
that actually that light itself
could have a particulate behavior
and that could be thought
of as consisting of little
particles each with energy h nu,
which we now call the photon.
So, and that introduced this strange idea
that light could at once
be a wave and a particle
because light interferes with itself
and we had a theory of light
waves, not of light particles.
So, Einstein eventually embraced the idea
that there was going to be a new theory
with wave-particle duality,
which is indeed what happens.
Now, one of the interesting things
is that quantization appears
somewhat naturally for waves
when they're confined, okay?
So for example if I tie
a string at two points
and I vibrate it,
then all of its vibrations
can be reduced to certain
quantize vibrations
with a fundamental half wavelength
and then the next overtone
with a full wavelength
and then three halves and so on
and this is the harmonic series
that a lot of people know in music,
and there's a natural quantization.
You cannot have frequencies
in between these allowed harmonics.
So if there was wave-particle duality
maybe that could lead to quantization.
Now actually, Einstein
focused his research
mainly on quantum theory,
not in relativity between 1907 and 1911,
and by the end of 1910 he gave up
and he wrote, the riddle of
radiation will not yield.
So, but just at that time actually,
all the other people who
had not quite recognized
the looming crisis in physics
they realized there was a crisis.
There was this famous
first Solvay Conference
in November 1911
on the topic of radiation and quanta,
and there you see, Mr. Solvay,
this wealthy industrialist
who paid for this,
not unlike events now at the
Aspen Institute, et cetara,
and there's Einstein,
but actually he was very disappointed
because he'd already run into a brick wall
and he wrote to his friend De Calabaso
that the conference was
like the Lamentations
on the ruins of Jerusalem.
I did not find it very stimulating
because I did not hear anything
that I did not already know.
So the next person then
to really make progress
was Niels Bohr,
who actually found out
about the Solvay
Conference from Rutherford
and he introduced this model of an atom,
where again you had quantization,
but this was quantization in
terms of different orbits.
Now, it was known by that time
that the atom consisted of a nucleus
which was positively charged,
and negative electrons,
and you could think of them
orbiting in a kind of solar system model,
but of course, in classical physics,
the orbits could have any radius,
but or proposed with some
justification, some argument,
not completely rigorous,
that only certain orbits would be allowed
and the only thing that could happen
is that an electron could
jump between these orbits
emitting energy h nu in the form of light,
and the interesting thing
is he could calculate these energy levels
and they were not equally spaced
like this harmonic oscillator
that we were just talking about
and so this spacing of the energy levels
depends a little bit on the
nature of the forces involved
and the equals h nu was just
true for harmonic oscillator
and then we knew how to calculate
the energy levels of atoms.
Okay, and because you
have different spacings,
then that means different
frequencies of light
can be emitted from the atom,
but they're discrete frequencies,
but this orbit picture
turned out to be wrong.
It took 13 more years
to really come up with a
more quantitative theory,
which is essentially the modern theory.
This was done mainly by
Heisenberg and Erwin Schrodinger,
and they replace this orbit picture
with the picture of clouds of probability.
There was this idea
that a state for an atom
would be not in orbit
and that the electron actually could be
in some sort of cloudy region
with a particular kind
of variation of the cloud
depending on how much energy it had.
It's related to this thing
called a wave function,
we'll be talking about a little bit,
and in this case the
position of the electron
in the wave function is uncertain.
You'll find it in different
places when you measure
for the same state,
but if you measure the energy
you'll always get the quantized energy,
and in this talk
and for what we're gonna do
in quantum information today,
I'm gonna mostly focus on
variables that are discrete,
like the energy here that can
only take quantized values.
Okay, so we're moving right
along with quantum mechanics.
So one thing that followed from the theory
that was invented in '25, '26 '27,
was that when an atom was emitting light
through this quantum jump,
that it could actually be
in between the two states,
in a state called a superposition
which we write this way.
So psi is this wave function
and it's proportional to an
equal sum of the two states,
and I'm being very vague
mathematically here,
but the meaning of the
superposition, at least partially,
was that when you measure
the energy of the electron
in a superposition,
50% of the time you would
get the energy level E2
and 50% of the time you
get the energy level E3.
Okay, and you also can have
unequal superpositions,
like you could have
something with a half there
and that would correspond to
finding E2 75% of the time
and E3 25% of the time.
Okay, so so far maybe
that's not too upsetting.
Now, to talk about this in
an information theoretic way,
we're gonna replace the two
levels by a zero and a one,
as in the states of a bit,
which we're gonna call a quantum bit,
but this is a bit that can be
in this superposition state
and while every quantum system
has usually many energy
levels or an infinite number,
in actual using it for
information processing
we're often gonna focus on
just two levels or a few,
and so we talk about this quantum bit
as if there were only two levels
until the other levels start to come in
and then we'll move away from that,
but mainly, we're gonna
talk about quantum bits.
Now, measuring a quantum
bit in superposition,
is this just the same as measuring a coin
that's been tossed inside a box, right?
So let's say it's a 50, 50 superposition.
So I toss a coin inside a box,
I don't look at it yet
and then when I open it up
I have a 50% chance of getting tails,
or I do it again, 50%
chance of having heads.
So, and then an unequal superposition
could be just like a biased coin,
which is somehow loaded to come up
more like heads and tails,
and more heads than tails.
So where's the big philosophical
problem with a bias coin?
I mean, it doesn't sound
like a total showstopper.
Okay, well, here's where it
starts to get more challenging.
Okay, so I do this, I don't look at it,
and then same thing, I do it again.
I get some value of heads or tails,
but when I finally opened the box
I'm able to assume that
before I opened the box
it had the value before
I actually could see it,
quote unquote, measure.
So the inability to predict heads or tails
when I toss a coin is
a matter of ignorance.
I don't know what it is
if I don't look at it,
but it was that before I mentioned.
So measurement just reveals the
state that was there before,
and you can't say this for quantum bits.
It really is not true
and so far as physics
can talk about truth.
So that's where things
start to get complicated
and now I'll try to explain why.
Okay, so the usual coin would be 50, 50,
we're gonna call it zero in one state,
but you know if it's biased
I could have a totally loaded coin
that's completely always comes up head
or always comes up tails,
or I could have anything in between,
say, comes up two thirds of
tails and one thirds head.
There's nothing surprising,
and all the different kinds
of probabilistic behavior
are on this line here,
but qubit states are not like that, okay?
This equal superposition I showed you
is like the 50, 50 unbiased coin,
but I can write a different quantum state
where I put a minus sign
in front of the state one
and that'll also be 50,
50 when I measure it,
and then there are nastier
ones that I'm not showing you
that involve complex numbers
and in fact, there's actually
an infinity of unbiased coins
and the states of a quantum bit
can't be described by a line,
they have to be described by this sphere
where always having one,
the totally biased coin,
is the two poles of the sphere, okay?
And the two states I just wrote here
would be on the equator of the sphere,
and the equator is a circle,
and so there's a continuum
of unbiased states
all of which are distinct,
and then when you measure the energy,
they could still gonna be 50, 50, okay.
After you measure the
energy, if you get one,
it's gonna stay one till something
else that manipulates it.
So the measurement has changed,
the state is now completely one
even though it started out in that state,
that was 50, 50, one and zero, okay.
So what makes all these
different unbiased states
on the equator of this
sphere different states?
Well, you can tell they're different
when you measure something
else, which is not the energy,
and to keep life simple we're gonna assume
you measure something, which is discrete
and could just be zero or one,
but a different meaning of zero or one.
Some other physical property
like momentum or something
else, angular momentum.
Now, these states on the
equator won't be unbiased
when you measure this other property,
and the bias will not be the same.
So they're not the same state
and they don't map on to just
a biased or unbiased coin.
Okay, so do we really have to accept
that the state is uncertain
until we measure it?
Could we still interpret our observations
as learning what was already there?
Which is certainly was
from the very beginning
the question that people ask
because they wanted to think of physics
as objective reality
independent measurement.
So the answer is no, we can't do that.
It seems like in quantum mechanics
measurement is affecting the system
and making it choose properties.
The properties are not independent
of the actual measurement,
and Bohr respond to this
by saying get over it.
This is known more formally
as the Copenhagen interpretation
or complementarity,
and he just says your
choice of measurements
determines what you can know
and there are questions
that don't have an answer,
you shouldn't expect them to have answers.
Later it was actually
proved that any new theory
which assumes properties of quantum bits,
they're independent of
how they're measured,
could never agree with all the predictions
of quantum mechanics,
and Bohr was, I'm fine with that.
Okay, but not Einstein.
So Einstein, famously in 1935,
wrote this paper with two young colleagues
at the Institute for Advanced Studies,
called can quantum mechanical description
of physical reality be
considered complete?
And in it he did a thought
experiment, he liked those,
in which he tried to argue
that it can't be considered complete,
and the reason that he argued,
his argument was related to
the concept of entanglement.
So entanglement is
again, I have two qubits,
I don't know what their state is, okay?
But I put them in a state
that has the property
that if I get the two of them,
and they're in a joint state,
and when I measure them,
if I know what one is,
I immediately find the other
one has to be the same.
So their values are called entangle.
Now each coin separately is unbiased,
it just comes up 50, 50 as entails,
but if I measure the second one,
actually it has to be the same.
These are these magic coins,
also known as EPR pairs,
after Einstein hold on all scheme rose.
So they look like this in our notation.
So you either get one
and one or zero and zero,
and you never get zero one or one zero.
So each coin individually
carries no information
because it's not biased,
but the correlation does,
the entanglement does carry information,
because something about this.
In this state, zero one will never happen
and one zero will never happen.
So you have one bit of information,
but it's shared between the two bits.
Now the thing that makes it even worse
and that Einstein particularly
objected to is the following.
Suppose I have these entangled state,
and I take one of the bits
and I let it fly off a great distance
like a light year, or something like that
and then I do the measurement
here and I find heads.
Well, since you have to get heads
on the other bit that's far away
and if I measured it first
it would have been random.
So it sort of feels like
this measurement here
affected the measurement over there.
Now it turns out you can prove
you can't send information
with this correlations.
So you can't go faster than light,
but still it looks very
impossible or very wrong,
and so how can a measurement
here affect the result there?
Einstein said it can't.
Sometimes he would make
fun of the whole idea
of measurement affecting
reality by saying,
do you really think the moon isn't there
when you aren't looking at it?
And he thought there
must be a better theory
where only things near each coin
determine what their value is,
and somehow you can still explain
the correlation that exists.
So this brilliant young
theorist back in '64, John Bell,
actually took up Einstein's challenge.
He said could there be a better theory?
Is that even allowed?
And he figured out the
following theorem, okay.
So in his theory, he
calculated the correlation
between two measurements of cubits,
I'm not gonna go into exactly
what kind of measurement that would be,
but it's similar to checking
which state it's in,
but it's a little more complicated,
and he calculated how this correlation
would vary with a certain angle
that you vary in the measurement,
and you see this blue
curve I'm calling quantum
and that's the prediction
that quantum mechanics
gives for this measurement
and the red curve Bell established
is the largest values you can have
for any theory that Einstein would like,
that only depends on the local variables,
and so he said, "Just
go up and look at this
"and see if we violate this inequality.
"If we don't, then quantum
mechanics is wrong,
"and Einstein friendly
theory could be there,
"could be found,
"but if we do violate this inequality,
"then we could never
explain it with a theory
"that Einstein would accept."
And so that's the
difference between these two
at this particular angle, this difference.
If we see this Einstein is wrong,
if we see oops,
if we see the red then
maybe Einstein was right,
and this young French
physicist Alain Aspect in '82
did a very good experiment to test this.
There were some earlier ones,
but this certainly was
one of the very best
first early ones,
and there's his curve
and you see it looks like the blue curve
and it violates what are
called Bell's inequalities.
So that means we'll never be able to get
the kind of theory that
Einstein was looking for
and we really have to accept
these weird properties of entanglement,
and really many, many
experiments have been done
and this kind of thing has been
verified in different forums
over and over again.
So the consensus is that the
world is really this weird.
Yes, the world is really that.
Okay, now Bell really
was kind of upset by this
and he wrote Einstein
was the rational man.
The reasonable thing that he
thought just doesn't work.
So he was hoping
that maybe you'd find a problem
with the quantum prediction,
but we didn't.
Okay, so to summarize
we've learned quantum mechanics, right?
Sort of.
Quantum systems can live
in an uncertain state
called a superposition.
Two level system of these
then it's considered a qubit.
That's a certain kind of superposition,
which we've talked about a lot,
and any quantum system
when you measure it,
it decides what state it's in,
it collapses into a state
with a certain value
of the thing you measured.
The probability of each state
is determined by what the
initial superposition was.
So it won't always be the same thing.
It's contradictory to assume
it always was in the state you measured
before you measured it.
That's the toughest
part of it uncertainly.
So this physicist Alexey Korotkov said,
in quantum mechanics you
don't see what you get,
you get what you see.
So finally, qubits can be in
this perfectly correlated state
while still behaving individually random,
and this is an example
of entanglement, okay,
and the state looks like that
or in coins it looks like that.
All right, so we're good here, right?
We've mastered quantum mechanics.
- [Florian] We've done it though.
- We've done it.
Okay, test tomorrow.
Come to this link.
So we've covered most
of the hard stuff, okay?
And now we're gonna
understand quantum computing
quantum information a little bit.
So much later in 1927 there
was the fifth Solvay Conference
and Einstein was there
looking like the more familiar Einstein.
There's Bohr, there's
Heisenberg, there's Schrodinger,
and then there's this guy
whose name was Paul Dirac.
Paul Dirac actually
right after Heisenberg,
kind of put quantum mechanics
in an extremely elegant form
and predicted new things
that other people hadn't figured out
and was generally
considered to be a genius,
and he said in 1929 that
the underlying physical laws
necessary for the mathematical theory
of a large part of physics
and the whole of chemistry
are thus completely known.
This is a famous quote.
The rest of the quote is often not given,
and he says, the difficulty
is only that the exact
application of these laws
leads to equations much too
complicated to be soluble.
It therefore becomes desirable
that practical methods of
applying quantum mechanics
should be developed.
Well, for the next 50 years,
quantum mechanics turned out
to be the theory of everything
and nobody really wanted to worry
about these foundational
issues and philosophical issues
and there was this acronym
SUAC, shut up and calculate,
which was enforced when I
started my PhD, for sure.
So you weren't supposed to
worry about these things
if you were serious about physics.
Now, but the dirty secret
was we know the equations
that would describe many complex systems
of atoms and molecules or
even subatomic particles,
but we often can't solve them, okay?
And this is due to something
that I call the the exponential wall.
Now, because of the pandemic
people are familiar
with exponential curve.
Like you infect one person
and each person there infects one more
so two turns into four into
six, et cetera, et cetera,
and it grows very quickly.
So it turns out that the
equations of quantum mechanics
are sort of like that,
in the sense that as the
system gets more complicated,
first, with the simple system
we can actually solve
it with pencil and paper
and give exams to undergraduates
expecting them to be able to do that,
and then as it gets more complicated
we have two atoms or three
then we turn to a computer,
but if we really try to
solve them exactly for,
I don't know, any medium-sized molecule,
and we we do that using a
ordinary digital computer
there is a brute force way
to solve these equations.
They're called partial
differential equations,
but we find
that as the number of atoms
and molecules increase,
the time that it's gonna take our computer
to crank out the answer is growing
and pretty soon we're estimating
that's gonna take the history of mankind
and then the history
of the earth and so on,
and so there's no way
to directly solve those
that we know prior to quantum
computing in human timescales.
Now, in many cases we
found approximate methods
that avoid the exponential wall
and seem to agree with nature.
So we've made a lot of progress,
but in the cases where we
don't have a good approximation
we can't predict anything.
So that is the dirty secret
and this really describes
many of the frontier problems
in theoretical physics
that we're trying to get
around the exponential wall.
Okay, now, getting back now
to quantum information, okay?
One of the few famous physicist
who was involved with the
quantum information fringe
was Richard Feynman,
I hope many of you have heard of him,
and in 1981, actually, I was there,
but I didn't know about this conference,
there was a conference on
the physics of computing
and Feynman came and
gave the keynote address
such as it was,
and he said, okay, now
that I'm blocking here
actually the quote, but you can see it.
Can you simulate nature with a
new kind of quantum computer,
it's not a Turing machine,
it's a machine of a different kind
with quantum computer elements.
Meaning the hardware itself
was in a quantum state of superposition,
or something like that,
and so he says it's not a Turing machine,
it's not what we now would
call a classical computer.
Well, nature isn't classical, dammit,
and if you want a simulation of nature
you better make it quantum,
and by golly it's a wonderful problem
because it doesn't look too easy.
So that's how Feynman talked
and he realized that maybe
this would get around
the exponential wall,
but this seemed like a crazy idea, right?
Because we've already told
you that quantum bits exists
in an uncertain state.
I haven't even told you
how fragile they are,
but even if you have them,
if they're in a superposition,
they may randomly fall
into one state or another.
So you can't even
reliably store your bits,
why would you want something
that could be a zero or a one?
So forget about processing
in some predictable way
to solve a problem.
You are introducing noise
and loss of information
at the basic hardware level,
how could that be good?
But as these people thought,
what if quantum weirdness
is a feature and not a bug?
And the basic idea of quantum simulation
is that if the components of your computer
can keep their quantumness
and are hooked up and are programmed
so that they have the same
kinds of interactions and forces
as the atoms in a molecule,
say that you're trying to
calculate the energy levels of,
then just by running your computer
there will be a way to
extract the energy level
that you can't actually
do with a normal computer,
just as this is just a
quantum analog simulator.
Now, I must hasten to say
that none of our computers before
ever had quantum components in this sense.
Okay, so if you did this
it turns out there would
be no exponential wall
and you would be able
to treat much larger
quantum systems predictably.
So throughout the '80s,
scientists explored the
properties of quantum information
and interesting things were found.
You can find the history
there on Wikipedia,
but really the big moment was in 1994.
So 1994 Peter Shor,
who was an applied mathematician
and computer scientist
at Bell Labs at the time,
he proved he was looking at this,
and quantum calculations aren't
the only exponential walls.
So as an applied mathematician
in computer science,
he was interested in
other exponential walls
and he had heard about this idea
of a potential quantum computer,
and he showed that a quantum computer
could solve a computer
science math problem
with an exponential wall,
which was believed to
have an exponential wall.
So in other words,
it wasn't just a way to
simulate quantum mechanics
and do physical science calculations,
it was also a way to solve
problems in Applied Math
that could apply to finance
to cryptography, et cetera,
where exponential walls are everywhere
in networking and
communications and so on.
Here's an example of a non
physics exponential wall
that probably you can relate to.
This is somebody's estimate
of the days of computer time
it would take to crack a
password of different length
in terms of letters.
So your desktop could
do up to five letters
and then it's gonna
start taking much longer
than you're willing to wait.
A graphical processing unit,
which is very fast for
gaming, it can go up to six,
and then an Amazon cloud cluster
can go up to seven or eight,
and it's very clear
that if you have 20
letters in your password,
you're never gonna get there.
So this is nothing to do with physics.
These are problems in information science
or in cryptography, rather,
that we want to know the answers to, okay.
So Shor showed that if you
had an ideal quantum computer
with perfect cubits and
other things perfect,
you could break the standard
encryption technology
which underlies web browsing
and e-commerce on the internet.
So this was a moment
that shocked the world.
Okay, so what am I talking about?
So cryptographers like exponential walls,
particularly if they're one-way walls,
that is that one way it's
very hard to find the answer,
but the other way when
you decrypt it's easy,
and factoring large
numbers into their primes
is a convenient one-way wall.
Mathematicians and computer
scientists knew this
and it's used in something
called RSA encryption,
which is used to send your
credit card on the internet.
Just to remind you what a prime number is
and a little bit about them.
So 20 is one times two
times two times five,
a prime number, well, okay.
21 is shown there, 22 is shown there,
and a prime number is...
I didn't show itself as
a factor, I should have.
A prime number has no
factors, but one and itself,
and I'm sure most of you
do remember that, I hope.
Now you might think, well,
we kind of just look at this
and we figure this out, it's true.
We could do that for not too big numbers,
but if they're really big numbers
then it's not easy to do.
So trying factoring this guy.
So this is not a randomly
chosen number that I typed.
This is RSA-2048.
It's a 617 decimal digit,
2,048 bits integer,
which is semi prime, I'll explain that.
So it's not a prime number
and it's one of the
largest longest numbers
that they use in this encryption scheme
that I'm gonna tell you about
and they offered many years ago $200,000
to factorize this number,
and as Wikipedia says
it may not be factorizable
for many years to come.
So RSA-2048 has only two prime factors
other than one and itself.
So p times q multiplied together
gives us this long number,
that it's very hard to figure out p and q.
Okay, and actually still
no person or computer system
on earth can find that
the factors p and q of this number
except the people that constructed it,
who hopefully are revealing it.
So you could offer somebody
billions of dollars.
This is an unsolvable problem, we believe,
at the moment with the
finest techniques we know.
So the team at RSA found p and q,
likely to find large primes,
and then they multiply them together,
and there is a way to find large primes.
So multiplying is easy, right?
That you could even probably do
although we could probably make a mistake
with this long number,
but a computer can do that easily,
but figuring out the prime factors
is believed to be exponentially hard
and have an exponential wall.
So there's a one-way
wall, it's easy to compute
and knowing p and q
it's quote unquote impossible,
p and q, knowing it, okay,
unless you have a quantum
computer post Shor, okay.
Now the way this is often illustrated
is we're going to send a message
that we wanna encrypt
between Bob and Alice
and each of those know the factors of N.
I'm not even sure they both have to,
but I'm just assuming that.
Okay, this is Bob's credit card number.
So he sends it
by encoding it in a message of
bits that depend on N, okay?
And he sends that message over
and then knowing the factors of N
Alice can decode it and get
a Bob's credit card number,
and if Eve is listening,
she's an eavesdropper,
or has corrupted the security of the line,
she will get an N
but she won't be able to
find the prime factors
and she won't be able to decode it,
and this is literally one of the main ways
that the internet allows you
to send your credit card securely.
So when Shor happened,
cryptographer first braced
for a quantum revolution
and by 2015 the US NSA
had revealed its intention
to transition to quantum
resistant protocols,
meaning that we won't use RSA,
we'll find some other method
that so far we haven't figured out
if a quantum computer could break, okay?
But we're still using it regularly
and we don't have a quantum computer
unless something very
surprising is out there
that could break RSA at the moment, okay.
So once the Shor algorithm
was invented, the race was on.
I mean, intelligence,
privacy, e-commerce, finance,
I mean, all these things care
about being able to crypt
and encrypt and decrypt, and so on,
and suddenly there was
this paradigm shift,
quantum uncertainty
wasn't always a barrier
to learning about nature.
Actually, it could be the key
to extracting previously
inaccessible knowledge,
and you had to invent new hardware
which would qualitatively
change the type of the problem.
So before we thought
that if a problem was exponentially hard
on one type of computer,
it would be exponentially
harder on any kind of computer,
but according to Shor's
result that's not true,
if you have the new
revolutionary quantum hardware
this exponentially hard
problem could become solvable.
Okay, now, it turns out
that all quantum speed up
derives from superposition
and entanglement.
So if nature wasn't like this
we could never solve these problems,
it would forever be outside of reach,
and it uses everything
Einstein hated about quantum mechanics.
So there's quite a historical
pioneer irony there,
and it's a new kind of machine,
never previously attempted
in science and technology.
So let me try to explain how
it could be, in some sense,
so much more powerful,
although this is a very
simplified illustration.
So this is a conventional computer,
a RAM chip with 100 billion bits on it
and each bit has two states.
So there are two to the N states
that this chip could hold,
two to the 100 billion is
an insanely large number.
In fact, 300,
two to the 300 is actually
an insanely large number.
It's 10 to the 91 states.
So if we were to explore
all states sequentially
at one nanosecond,
so we just turned on this chip
and started with all zeros
and then flipped one and then another,
just did this once a nanosecond, okay,
it would take greater than the
age of the universe, sorry.
It would take longer
the age of the universe
to just do this in a serial classical way,
but in a quantum computer
would take less than a second.
So we start with all zeros
in the quantum version
and we don't flip one,
we actually superposed it.
We turn it into an equal
superposition of zero and one,
which is something we
know how to do, okay?
And then we do that for the
next one and the next one,
and eventually when
we've done that 300 times
we actually have all 10 to
the 91 terms in this big sum,
all of which are now being
partially implemented
in this 300 bit quantum register.
So in that sense
it does something completely
impossible classically,
but very doable, quantum mechanically,
and this would take
less than a millisecond
actually, on a quantum computer.
We think we don't have one yet,
but so the quantum computer
is the ultimate parallel processor,
but it may also be the
most difficult technology
we've ever tried to build.
So why is it quantum computer
insanely difficult to build?
Okay, classical bit is high or low voltage
in a small circuit
and the bit can just stay
there uncorrupted for years
or a magnetic region and
a magnetic disk, whatever.
The quantum bit is a real artificial atom
with quantum levels, okay?
So there's a real atom and
there's an artificial atom.
This is one of the ones pioneered at Yale,
where I have a superconducting structure
that has energy levels,
and can be treated as a kind
of artificial atom, okay,
but the unprotected qubit,
if I just leave it out in the environment
it's going to just go away
in a nanosecond, okay.
It just can't stay in some superposition,
and the reason it can't
is because being out in the
world is in an environment
where atoms are bumping into,
where light is coming in,
radiation is coming in,
and it's measuring the qubit
and it's making it decide
what state it's in,
even though humans don't measure it,
the environment is measuring it.
So that's why quantum information
is incredibly fragile.
This effect is called decoherence,
and that's why we couldn't
have a real Schrodinger cat
because anything big and living like a cat
is interacting with the
environment to stay alive
and so it not gonna be
in a superposition, okay?
But so quantum information
is like the most fragile kind
of information ever invented.
Okay, well, that sounds hard,
but can't we just shield our
qubits from the environment
and keep them far apart from each other?
I mean, we know how to
trap individual atoms,
20, 30 years ago,
we can cool things down.
Can we just do that?
Well, that's not enough, okay?
Because you need to interact
your qubits to process.
For example, you need
to create entanglement.
So here's my qubit, one
that's in state one.
Let's say I wanna put
it into a superposition.
So insert it with some microwaves or laser
and I put it into zero
one in a controlled way,
and I have to bring my next qubit in,
that's also in that superposition.
No one entangled.
So I wanna get rid of the
one zero, zero one state,
so they have to talk to each other
and eventually I'll end up
with the entangled state.
So I had these interactions
that have to go perfectly.
Any mistake, I'm not
gonna get the right state.
So this is so difficult
that we think we will need
error correction in hardware,
which we do have in classical computers.
We store one as three ones
and then take the majority and so on,
but it's much harder to do
what possible to do in quantum mechanics.
Now the current quantum computers,
they're basically two main technologies.
The one that was pioneered
here at Yale and other places
involves the superconducting circuits
that you cool down to
a hundredth of a degree
above absolute zero,
and then these artificial
atoms are on chips.
They're little superconducting regions
that are specially designed.
This approach was
pioneered by my colleagues,
Michelle Devoret, Steve
Girvin, and Rob Schoelkopf,
I wanna shout out to them
and this is called a transmon qubit
which pretty much all the
industrial places are using them.
Now the other approach
is to use real atoms
and this blue thing here is
a string of trapped ions,
so ionized atoms,
which can be manipulated with laser beams
and has to be kept in an old dry vacuum.
So that's also extremely
fragile, but okay.
So we immediately see
that quantum computers
are not gonna be small,
they're not gonna be portable,
and they're not gonna be cheap,
but they are going to...
Because they have unique capability
you can imagine that a quantum cloud
would still be very, very
powerful and desirable.
Now you might worry that
while it's pretty easy
to think that a single
ion suspended in space
is sort of not near its neighbors,
stuff on a chip,
where we have solids made of other atoms,
you might say it's
probably quite difficult
to make that type of
qubit avoid decoherence,
and it was quite difficult.
Back in the '90s
when they were first
proposed and demonstrated,
you had about a nanosecond
before they became useless
and then over the last, what is it?
Sort of 20ish years,
there's been six order
of magnitude improvement
so that we can store quantum
information on a chip
and most of this improvement
was done by people at Yale.
Also the world leader in
quantum error correction,
which I don't have time to go into.
So in the last three minutes here
let me say something about
what quantum computing
could do for mankind.
So this is a picture of Einstein again.
Gotta get him in there with
his friend, Fritz Haber,
and Haber invented something
called the Haber-Bosch process
in the beginning of the 20th Century,
and it's a way to extract
nitrogen from the air
and make ammonia.
Ammonia is a very critical
component fertilizer
and this led to the Green Revolution
of the second half of the 20th Century,
and it's actually a very tough bond
to break this nitrogen bond.
So it's very energy intensive
and it has to be done
it 250 bars of pressure,
which is the pressure
two and a half kilometers under the sea,
and at 450 degrees centigrade,
which is the melting point of aluminum.
So it's very energy intensive
and it emits a lot of
CO2 when you do this.
In fact, the National Academy of Sciences
estimated that 1% of total
US energy for gas or oil,
and what does it say net
energy and natural gas
is used yearly, just for
the Haber-Bosch process.
So 1% of all the energy
we use goes into this
and creates a lot of CO2.
So a grand challenge in quantum chemistry
would be to figure out
how we could do this much
less energy intensively,
and here's this co-factor called Fe-Mo Co
which if you let bacteria have it,
they can produce nitrogen from soil
at room temperature and pressure
instead of the pressure of the
bottom of the sea and so on,
and we don't know how they do it.
It's too complicated.
We don't know enough about the
properties of this co-factor
to figure out.
If we did,
maybe we could actually turn
it into industrial process
and save an enormous amount of energy.
Another example I like
is something related
to biomedical science,
and this case these guys Sels and Demler,
they talked to medical biophysicists
to ask what could a quantum
computer do for you.
Since Demler seems to be
married to a biophysicist,
this was probably relatively easy,
and they talked about this
metabolic dark matter.
So we all know about genomics
and some people know
about cataloging all the
proteins, proteomics,
but then the next level of
functional things in the body
are called metabolites,
and they're 200,000 metabolites
and we only know what
1% of them do and so on
and so we'd like to know that,
but the way we try to figure it out
was by shining NMR radiation on them
and looking at the signal we get back,
and this is very sparse information,
and from this signal
it's very hard to figure out
a complicated structure, okay?
And so this is how we're doing it now,
but we can't do it that well
and Sels and his co-workers
designed an algorithm
which uses a combination
of pattern recognition
and AI and quantum simulation
to identify metabolites from spectrum,
and it used the Shor-like speed up.
The same thing that Shor used
to speed up factorization
and they did some examples
and they were able to
reproduce known spectra.
You might say, well, how did they do that
'cause they don't have a quantum computer?
And the answer is they only did it
up to the exponential wall
and they're just hoping
if we get a quantum computer
it can go through the exponential wall,
but they're checking
that the idea is working
with a classical computer
simulating a quantum computer.
Okay, so that's all I wanted to get across
about how exciting and
interesting the next phase is
and how philosophically
and conceptually important
the common information revolution is.
So we're going boldly
into the quantum future
and we at Yale hope to be
finding out what happens there.
Thank you for your attention.
- [Florian] There's a little
visual typing happening.
Thank you so much for this talk doc.
We have a question from Annie.
You talked a little bit
about what quantum computer could do.
Can you tell us for...
The question is what
kind of complex problem
can quantum computer have solved so far?
- Okay, maybe I didn't make this clear.
So there aren't quantum computers really.
I mean, they're very,
very kind of rudimentary
and people are using them,
but at the moment we
have dozens of qubits,
not even 100 that work together,
they don't work together
flexibly and so on.
So there is no quantum computer
that's really doing stuff yet.
That's groundbreaking stuff.
There are lots of little
examples of things they're doing.
The first thing people
are doing is to try to,
not the first thing but
one of the first things
is to look at actual molecules
because that's kind of
a very natural thing
for quantum simulation
and we have bigger quantum simulators
and multipurpose computers.
So that's the kind of things going on,
but so far just looks really promising,
nothing's been shown yet.
- [Florian] And I guess
the question that I have
and I have multiple regression
that is it doesn't exist yet,
but like when do you think it will happen?
- Well, I'm not--
- [Florian] I think that's
the million dollar question.
- So my colleague Rob Schoelkopf,
I hope I quoted correctly,
I think to have something
that you really can learn how
to use the quantum computer
and start doing things,
which I'd say we're not
even quite there yet,
that's gonna be only five
years maybe, maybe less.
The breakthrough, the change
in human society, the economy,
I don't know.
I don't think it's either
gonna fail massively
or it's gonna be here in 20 years,
but that's just my gut feelings.
There's been unbelievable progress made.
So that's my gut feeling,
but this is all over the map
and a lot of people are
saying it's already here,
we're already doing it,
you can buy our web services.
So you're gonna hear all the big spectrum
of answers to that question.
- [Florian] Are there any problem
where even quantum computer
can hit the exponential wall
you were talking about earlier?
- Well, a partially answer to this.
Well, first, yes,
in the sense that we don't know
the full capabilities
of a quantum computer,
and so there are lots of
problems of exponential walls
and we haven't figured
out a quantum algorithm
to solve them fast,
and I don't know whether
there's any proofs
that they don't exist ones,
but specifically, the new
kinds of coding problem
your coding may wanna do,
they're gonna use another math problem
not factoring prime numbers, I'm sorry,
finding prime factors of large numbers.
They're gonna use a different
kind of hard math problem
where nobody has come up
with a quantum algorithm
and I think some people are
much further along than me
in understanding which ones
can and cannot be solved,
but certainly there are many
exponentially hard problems
we haven't figured in quantum algorithms.
Another thing I wanna mention is that,
and this is now I'm quoting
a very knowledgeable person
from Microsoft, Matthias Troyer,
who said that quantum computing
is gonna be good for
hard compute problems,
not for big data problems.
So if there's some place in the program
or in the calculation,
where there's an exponential wall,
you'll use a quantum computer.
If you wanna have
massive storage and so on
and be able to use it,
actually, you're gonna
use a classical computer
that's gonna be easier in certain ways.
So that was his general take on it.
So networking and the kinds of things
that Google wanna do is very
much a hard computer problem.
- [Florian] I'm gonna
be talk about Google.
That's a perfect segue
to the next question.
Somebody is asking what did Google do
with the quantum computer effort last year
and the quantum supremacy?
- So the,
- And how's it different?
- The idea that emerged,
which was a reasonable idea,
was that well, let's find
a problem which has an exponential wall,
that may be the easiest problem
to make quantum hardware for,
and let's show that we can get an answer
when no classical computer could.
So it is not a useful problem
and there's big arguments
about whether it's even
an interesting problem.
I heard both sides argued recently here
in the Quantum Institute,
but it wasn't a practical problem.
So they did a kind of sorting problem,
that's not even right,
but it's essentially a statistical problem
where you had to detect a
certain statistical behavior
that was characteristic of interference
in quantum mechanics
and you could try to simulate that problem
on a classical computer
and they got to a size
where no classical computer could do it
and they got an answer
which looked to be measuring
quantum interference.
It was not dramatic (laughs).
The quantum mechanics
predicted to and they got 1.06.
So their computer was
not working perfectly,
but they claimed that
in classical computer
couldn't have even gotten the 0.06.
So it was a very abstract problem
that they wanted to
claim quantum supremacy.
So, but I think the fact
that they got so close
is showing that we're making progress
and there are different approaches.
Our approach here at Yale
has been to try to do
quantum error correction
and do much cleaner quantum computations
with smaller numbers of bits and so on,
and so that's the approach we've chosen.
Google has chosen one approach,
IBM is more or less going more
in our direction and so on.
So yes, it was a big deal
'cause it did show something
beyond what a classical computer could do.
So in that sense it's big,
but it's a tiny, tiny
inch above the threshold.
I mean, it's not anything dramatic yet.
- [Florian] Somebody asked the question,
I've noticed there's a lot of physicists
working on these topics with
the background in physics,
what are the possibility
for engineers in this field?
- So from my understanding
from talking to Rob Schoelkopf,
the director of this institute
who founded the QCI, this startup company,
oh, sorry, what do I need to do?
Okay, sorry, is that actually
more than half the people
or half the people are engineers
and software engineers and so on.
So I think it's very
clear that this is a field
where we'll need lots
of electrical engineers,
computer scientists, software engineers,
probably mechanical engineers.
Anyway, so there's a lot
of opportunity there,
but the big barrier, the
exponential wall here,
is that you have to understand something
about quantum mechanics
and so we're working
on educational courses
that can take someone without
a full physics background
and they could just use my talk,
but it's probably not quite
deep enough to do that.
So yes, there will be a
big role for engineers.
- [Florian] And then we can also say
that the Yale Quantum Institute
regroups departments out here
in physics, applied physics,
computer science, electrical
engineering, chemistry,
so we're really trying to bring a very--
- It's naturally interdisciplinary
and also at least for the moment,
it's like a seller's market.
So anybody with quantum
training that's legit
you can get hired maybe
without doing any postdoc
or maybe out of your PhD,
but we don't like that.
So forget I said that.
- [Florian] Thank you,
there's a lot more question pouring in.
What in particular do you see the YQI team
contributing to the coming decades?
Like, what's next, what do
you think that the Yale labs
will bring in the field?
- Thank you, I don't know.
This is a Yale person.
- [Florian] It's an anonymous thing.
Maybe somebody from
Yale is sending us that,
like a local question for us.
- Okay, so I didn't
wanna be too parochial,
but I think that,
I mean Yale deserves a lot of credit,
both for inventing a lot
of the foundational stuff,
but for taking a completely different
and very patient systematic approach,
and in doing that they've
actually changed the paradigm
and only a few other places.
As of last year no one
but Yale was doing this.
I understand now some other
people are doing this,
and they stopped using the
superconducting circuits
as their artificial atoms.
They started actually using
photons, light in cavities,
and I don't have a picture here,
but it doesn't look like the flat thing
that I have here, right?
The new thing looks like something
you might have on your cable box.
Yeah, it doesn't look like that flat thing
that I have in this picture.
It's three dimensional and it's small,
it's not as big as your cable box,
but it looks very different,
and that's 'cause we're
storing information in light
and the reason we're storing
information in light,
or in photons, actually,
microwave photons,
is because photons don't interact strongly
and they have fewer ways that
they can actually disappear,
and so we've already shown
that they can have 10
times longer lifetimes
than the superconducting
qubits we used to use.
So, and we hope to pioneer
this method of using storage with photons
and processing with
superconducting elements,
which is unique to Yale and now
it's spreading a little bit,
and then the second thing
is that we hope to add error correction,
efficient error correction
way before anybody else,
and I won't tell you, it
gets pretty technical,
why we think we are so far ahead,
but we have good reasons to think this.
- [Florian] We've gotten a
lot of question in the Q&A
regarding like the investment of China
on quantum computing.
They are wondering what are
the the implication of this,
and if they will have gone a bit before,
but I think you've answered
this question saying like,
we hope that the Yale team has something.
- Well, so I think that
the idea of encryption,
and sending encrypted
messages is very exciting
to the Chinese and lots
of people to be fair,
and they've been really
pushing quantum communication,
not quantum computing.
I guess they're catching up
somewhat in quantum computing,
and one of the things I didn't get to say
is that there is a proof
that you can send
unbreakable coded messages
with quantum mechanics,
and that is out there already
and it's being sold commercially.
We don't know who's using it in defense.
So I think they're very much
interested in the secrecy,
coding, decoding aspect of it
more than the quantum
computing at the moment,
but that's just a guess.
- [Florian] I think the clock is running
and I'm gonna maybe end on this question.
Since we're a university
we have a question from a college student.
Willis asking like what
could a student do today
to prepare for quantum
computing in the future?
What are the subjects or
major you should consider?
Is it better to do CS or physics?
Like what is your take on a young person
who wants to join the efforts?
- I think that both are very good.
So you should do what you like more,
specifically, Shor who was not
trained in quantum mechanics,
but just kind of understood
the math of quantum mechanics
was able to find this thing
that he knew stuff in computer science
and in complexity theory
that most physicists at
that time didn't know,
and he made the revolution, honestly,
so he started the revolution.
So in that sense you can master the math
and do something as a computer scientist
or applied mathematician.
Being a physicist if you
wanna work on hardware,
that's definitely a good
idea to be a physicist,
or if there are joint efforts
between physics and engineering,
you could be an engineer.
So that would be an answer,
I think either are promising.
- [Florian] There's also the
question he had it was like,
he was worried about having his work
and computer science being obsolete
since the field is moving so fast,
and so that was also one of the concern,
and I think in that case
people here working
really in collaboration.
We've talked a lot with the
people in computer science here
and so I think the field is
moving along and so yeah.
- I also I sort of said this,
but I said it fast,
and maybe it's a good thing to end on.
You're not gonna have a
quantum computer in your phone,
you're not gonna have a
quantum computer in your house.
You don't need a quantum
computer in your house,
you're not always running up
against big compute problems
with exponential walls.
Google is running up against them
when they're trying to route signals
and do stuff over a
billion links and so on.
So it's not a replacement
for all of the classical
computing and software
or anything like that.
So clearly you're not
gonna be totally obsolete
unless you're very interested
in complexity theory,
and even then it won't
be obsolete, I suspect.
- [Florian] I think we're
gonna end on that note.
Thank you so much for tuning in.
We have a lot of unanswered questions.
They were actually very technical.
So maybe in the future we'll
have another event like this
for a slightly more technical
approach with the Q&A system
and maybe a moderate conversation.
Thank you so much for tuning in.
- We can bring in people
that know more than quantum.
- [Florian] You should
consider subscribing
to our public event newsletter
that you can find on our website,
quantuminstitute.yale.edu/subscribe.
Thank you all so much,
and thank you, Doug,
for taking the time to tell us
all about quantum computers.
Have a great night.